[Music]
[Music]
so this is a pretty great phone so I've
been using one plus six everyday now for
about two weeks and it is absolutely
daily driver material I think people who
buy it who know what they're getting
themselves into will like it a lot and
it's pretty easy to recommend so that's
right off the top really the more
interesting part is reviewing this phone
for me has become an exercise in a study
of the law of diminishing returns the
law of diminishing returns is a point at
which the level of benefits gained is
less than the amount of money or energy
invested so you see a 300 hour phone you
get a certain amount of value then you
spend 300 hours more and you get a lot
more value you spend 300 dollars more
than that you get a little more value
and then you spend another $400 more and
you get just a tiny bit more so honestly
the most important feature of the 1 plus
6 is the price it starts at 529 bucks in
this world of 7 800 $900,000 flagship so
they're kind of working in the reverse
direction instead of pushing value as
high as you possibly can they're kind of
thinking how much can we cut off of the
price without sacrificing a significant
amount of value how cheap can we make
this phone and still make it great and
every year one plus does this they have
to make this balance of things they want
to cut out versus things they want to
keep and I think this year they've made
a bunch of good choices and come out
with a balanced budget performance beast
so this year is a 2018 version of that
I'll give you the updates of what I
found from my experience which is most
of it being positive and then I'll fill
you went on the short cut so the
shavings they had to take because you
don't get to this price without some of
these so on the outside the build is
legit awesome the actual look of the
phone might not speak to everyone but
I'm a fan of the midnight black here or
the matte black version while there's
also a much glossy er much fingerprint
here mayor black and I was also a soft
white coming soon it has these awesome
buttons
I love these clicky buttons it has the
alert slider that's firm and also clicky
and I was actually confusing it with the
power button pretty early when I first
got this phone just because of the
placement it's kind of high but after
using it for a while I stopped doing
that and
the whole phone has this nice wedge
shape phones don't necessarily have to
be thin for me to like them but this
phone feels super solid with a lot of
metal in there it has a headphone jack
it has a dual SIM card tray and it even
has this subtle S shape when you see it
in the frosted glass back it's clean so
overall it honestly looks and feels
quality it has the slight bump in the
back to the camera that's not really a
big deal but for the emissions there are
some conscious choices that they made to
leave out of this phone that they're
hoping that you won't mind so much so
ready for these there's no expandable
storage just dual SIM cards so no micro
SD card expansion the speaker situation
is pretty weak it just has this single
downward facing speaker which is the
worst part of the phone's hardware it's
pretty average at best kind of tinny at
high volumes and there's no second
speaker in a earpiece to make a stereo
sound so it's super easy to block this
one by accident I've done it the
fingerprint reader on the back it's not
that bad but it's a little bit smaller
it used to be a full circle now the
smaller surface area is a bit of a
bummer
there's no wireless charging so most
phones nowadays with glass backs are
doing it to enable wireless charging
since it doesn't work through metal
oneplus has gone with the glass back but
didn't add wireless charging and then
it's also not officially IP rated for
water resistance oneplus kind of just
says like it's okay if you splash water
on it it'll survive daily use but they
don't officially ip67 or ip68 rated so
keep that in mind so it has a bunch of
great upside a bunch of you know great
build great materials great construction
but all those other little things that
you have to weigh against that now on
wireless charging I gotta say the
battery situation of the 1 plus 6 is
really interesting this is gonna sound
like I'm just defending one plus for not
putting in wireless charging look they
could have they definitely could have
put it in with this glass back and it
would have been great but I don't really
miss it on this phone the combination of
this battery it's a 3300 milliamp hour
battery decent size plus the near stock
Android with oxygen OS + at 1080 P
AMOLED display plus a Snapdragon a 45
with eight gigs of RAM I'm getting like
6 plus hours every single day of screen
on time
I'm getting a plus battery life if I
don't use it that much it's like ending
the day
forty percent it's really good and then
on top of all that you throw in there -
charging which is still on this phone
it's still the fastest 0 to 100 charging
I've ever seen in a phone it's super
convenient and when you have all that it
just kind of feels like I don't need
wireless charging it would be nice
it'd be cool but it's not a deal breaker
for me and I think one plus is hoping
that it's not a deal breaker for you
either so there's that but now let's
let's talk about that 1080p display
oneplus has stuck to their guns and
they're going with yet again a 1080p
optic AMOLED display six point three
inches from corner to corner so it's
huge and this time with a notch up at
the top it's part strategy part
sacrifice the resolution 20 to 80 by
1080 is actually hugely beneficial for
battery life as I mentioned it's also
pretty great for performance you're not
pushing nearly as many pixels which
means your GPU is not working as hard
everything is super smooth but also now
it's not going to be as sharp as the
galaxy s 9s and the pixels to excels of
the world which have quad HD displays
but then again like we saw in the pixel
quality control isn't easy and a great
1440p panel is not cheap or easy to find
so instead of settling for an average
quad HD screen to save money this phone
has what I'd say is the best-looking
1080p OLED in any phone right now it
gets really bright it's colorful
there's a couple different display modes
for different color profiles with
different amounts of saturation it's
good the best part of this display is
actually the clever way hey oneplus has
handled the notch up at the top but now
that we're getting deeper into this
whole world of Android phones having
notches and Android P coming out with
knotch support and developers getting
onboard we're seeing less and less apps
with those bugs that are cut off by the
notch so that's just kind of where we're
at I think a lot of manufacturers here
everyone complaining about that notch
though including oneplus so there's
plenty of that they're doing to hide it
if you really hate it in fact as you get
around to using the oneplus 6 you'll
notice the display setting lets you hide
the notch anytime if you don't want to
use it works great with an OLED display
those are black pixels and when you're
actually in apps you almost never lose
actual real estate in the app actually
you never lose real estate in the app
like back in the days of the essential
phone it would actually be cutting into
the app you're using it doesn't do that
anymore unless you actually go into the
display menu and turn on a full screen
mode and and explicitly give that app
permission so by default unlike the
iPhone it doesn't cut off YouTube videos
this is the same as the p20 Pro and
other phones with notches now you still
see everything and you can turn on
full-screen mode if you're cool with the
notch interrupting part of the app
you're in if you're not into it
you never have to turn that on so that's
clean and oxygen OS just as a whole is
fast and smooth as it is it also has a
pretty good amount of extra features
while still staying pretty close to
stock Android there's still the super
fast facial recognition there is the
gaming mode that doesn't let
notifications interrupt your gameplay
there's an ambient display mode that's
new that works when you raise your phone
up but it's not always on so I actually
don't even really bother using it
basically it's not lacking features so
you can already know I tend to keep my
setup pretty clean and this phone
definitely lets me do that now for
software updates when you think about
the longevity of the phone this is
actually one of the first of like maybe
six phones to get included in the
Android P beta program alongside the
pixel so now it's not just the pixel
this is one of those phones you can put
the Android P beta on and that's a
pretty good sign as far as the future of
when it'll get updates being close to
stock Android it doesn't necessarily
guarantee it's gonna get the same update
timing as the pixel you still probably
have to get a pixel to be first in line
for that but it probably does mean it'll
be better than your Samsung's and LG's
many months down the road so that's
pretty good I really like oxygen OS
still it's clean nothing's too
in-your-face it has a few quirks and a
few extra things like the shelf that put
a lot of useful information at your
fingertips but doesn't overwhelm you and
you can always hide most of it so I'm a
fan
pretty much the only thing I don't like
about the software here is the new
gestures I tried them for a while and
they do work perfectly fine there's no
bugs or anything and they are intuitive
but they're just not smooth like I'm so
used to the iPhones gestures being
extremely responsive and smooth to my
touch and you got to give Apple credit
for that and oneplus swipe gestures are
just not that so I'm sticking to the
buttons on this phone
so really the last big question we have
that we're wondering about from the
impressions video is the camera
situation on the 1 plus 6 well if you
saw the last video you saw the blind
test you probably already have some
thoughts about it from me it's like a
b-plus as
camera quality and smartphone but that's
because the a-plus smartphones the the
pixel twos of the world and the iPhone
10 and the Galaxy S nine are way up
there those are the eight $900,000
flagships so this is a B+ as far as
cameras but it's an A+ for the price it
is definitely better than other $500
phones this guy is a 16 megapixel
primary camera with optical
stabilization and an F 1.7 aperture and
it takes pretty nice shots I've been
shooting with it pretty confidently for
a while
focus is fine overall there's plenty of
detail and not a lot of noise and pretty
accurate colors if anything it biases
maybe a little towards overexposing more
often than under but dynamic range is
good enough that that hasn't been a
problem and every photo is plenty
saturated so overall I'd say I'm pretty
satisfied with the photos from the 1
plus 6 camera I'm not blown away or
anything I'm not super excited to use it
but satisfied that's second camera we
were wondering about it's not a
telephoto camera is just another 20
megapixel sensor with no OIS it's
basically used for depth information for
portrait mode as far as we can tell
which is okay I guess it's decent it's
not great I'm not gonna go out of my way
to use it that much but basically the
idea is it doesn't take photos that are
quite at the level of the highest end
flagships but those flagships are so
much more expensive this definitely
beats any other $500 phone in fact
that's really the theme for this whole
one plus 6 if you've noticed the whole
review it's either
knocking at the door of those flagship
smartphones or it's like one small step
behind but that is definitely beating
any other 5 $600 Android phone the specs
are ridiculous Snapdragon 805 6 or 8
gigs of ram i have 128 gigs of storage a
16 megapixel camera 3300 milliamp hour
battery that's knocking out the door of
like the highest-end flagships we have
right now definitely better than any
other 500 ollar phone it's your glass
and metal build it's your quality
construction great buttons it might be
missing wireless charging and a good
speaker and IP certification but it has
dual SIM it has a headphone jack it has
USB see really fast charging great
battery life huge AMOLED display
definitely better than other five 600
other phone the camera like we said is
B+ maybe but that's like we said way
better than any other
six-hundred allah fund which makes it
feel like a plus for the price this is
both literally and figuratively the most
polished phone one-plus has ever made I
think the choices they made really of
what to keep versus what to cut out
balanced out to a quality phone it would
have been so easy to review this phone
like a $900 flagship and just bash it
for like not having wireless charging or
not having an A+ camera but they did a
really good job and it's a great phone
for the money a plus for the price
that's been it let me know what you
think thanks for watching talk to guys
the next one peace